We've talked a little bit,
I think in this,
in this series about Pinocchio,
but if we have it doesn't matter.
Um,
you see there's Jimminy cricket at
the opening of the Pinocchio movie
pointing to a star,
which is roughly the Nativity
Star for all intents and purposes.
And it's um,
it's a symbolic indicator of
something diamond light and pure,
right glimmering in the darkness that's
transcendent and above the horizon upon
which to fix your eyes.
And so that's the thing is
you need that technically.
And the reason you need that is because
we know enough about psychology now to
know that almost all of the positive
emotion that you're going to experience in
your life and positive emotion
is analgesic by the way,
right?
It actually quells pain.
So it's not just positive.
It also gets rid of negative,
which is a big plus.
Almost all the positive emotion
that you're going to feel.
You're going to feel in relationship to
a goal because you feel positive emotion
as you approach a goal.
And so if you want to
feel positive emotion,
then you need a goal.
And then you might think,
well,
if you want to maximize
that positive emotion,
which is enthusiasm and also what
pulls you out into the world as well as
feeling good,
then you need the best possible goal.
Well that because that's going to engage
the largest segments of the year being
like if your goal is too narrow,
then a bunch of you isn't
going to be on board for it.
You know?
If the goal is well
developed and multifaceted,
then all of you can partake in that.
Even your negative elements,
even your anger and your fear
can get on board with that,
let's say so you need a goal,
man,
that's worthy.
You got us.
Thank you.
Good.
You need a goal that justifies the
tragedy and malevolence of life.
That seems to be the bottom line.
Now maybe you think,
well,
there's no goal that can do that.
It's like,
well,
there are still better and worse schools,
so and I,
I'm not convinced that there
are no goals that can do that.
I think that's an open question.
You'd never know that until you pursued
the proper goal long enough to find out
who you would be as a
consequence of pursuing it.
That's also your destiny
or your existential voyage,
right?
It's also not something that
anyone else can do for you.
Someone can say,
get your act together for
Christ's sake and get it.
Get good at it.
That's,
that'll make the world
unfold best for you.
But there's no way you can
know that without doing it.
And unless you think you've done a
particularly stellar job of that,
then you have no reason to
doubt its potential validity.